[Musique]
le monde savait possible par les
missions à des tarifs allégés 6
commentaires laissant les américains usa
ont eu un mérite d'été 2020 ils ont dit
on met le paquet nous on n'a pas été
assez vite assez fort là dessus c'est
tout à fait vrai nadine blues l'été ce
but il faut une explication fait plus
qui est qui et pourquoi la 12è gaspille
pour qu'aussitôt reste la figure comme
ont repris 4 cdma qui que ce soit mais
aucune de ce que j'étais dimanche il est
monté en passant ne sont pas venus donc
en fait il y avait plus de 30 doses je
crains qu'on va continuer d'entendre de
lakovic parler de la colline 19 dans la
décennie qui vient
elle vivra pas de la même façon mais je
ne vois pas la situation revenir à la
normale avant la fin de la décennie
actuelle est donc là dessus on a sans
doute en quelque sorte moins rêver aux
étoiles que certains autres et je pense
ça doit être une leçon pour nous mêmes
on a eu tort de manquer d'ambition
c'est à dire de folie oui de dire c'est
possible et on y va on est trop
rationnel peut-être cette situation elle
est extrêmement préoccupante avec une
troisième vague qui fera peu notre pays
en particulier l'île de france de
manière extrêmement forte
ça fait référence à cette fameuse
troisième vague qui est décrite par un
autre médecin lors d'une garde aux
urgences le week-end dernier voir la
troisième vague
en direct c'est impressionnant j'avoue
être des plus dépité un tube et une
patiente de 47 ans sans aucun antécédent
et sans facteur de risque quand on l'a
induites elle a pleuré et sans surprise
il annonçait que trois départements
basculé il s'agit de la nièvre du rhône
et de l'aube pour ces trois départements
il est apparu indispensable d'amplifier
les mesures de protection à les stocker
mercredi donc il est bon non du tac au
tac en grec match nul 3 à 3 et paris ce
taux
kalinic tard autrement dit merci et
bonne soirée à compter de ce vendredi
minuit et pour quatre semaines donc dans
ces trois départements le couvre-feu
continue de s'appliquer
de 19 heures à 6 heures les
rassemblements en extérieur ne doivent
pas dépasser six personnes les
déplacements sont autorisés de 6 heures
à 19 heures lorsque c'est dans un rayon
inférieur à 10 km sans attestation sans
limitation de durée
vas y ait des discussions aussi érudite
avec le président macron je parle du
grès couramment avait les discussions
étaient pas très orthodoxe l'egypte qui
déploient des efforts pharaonique pour
débloquer un porte-conteneurs qui est
coincé depuis hier en travers du canal
de suez
oui c'est l'une des routes commerciales
les plus fréquentées du monde des
dizaines de navires sont bloqués
derrière et ça a fait bondir les cours
du pétrole à new york d'ailleurs je
serai candidat à l'élection
présidentielle de 2000 22
je passe ma candidature au dessus des
partis en dehors des partis politiques
c'est la logique était celle de la vème
république du général de gaulle une
élection présidentielle c'est la
rencontre d'un homme d'une femme de son
projet avec les français c'est votre
candidat valérie boyer vous êtes chez
les républicains
oui mais je crois que saviez bertrand
n'y est plus alors oui enfin on verra
donc certains voudront participer à des
primaires certains voudront organisé je
respecte leur choix mais je redis que
toute façon que je travaillerai avec
tous et que je souhaite les rassembler
autour de mon projet ne peut pas gagner
sans nous et par conséquent il faut
voilà que respecter son calendrier il
faut qu'il respecte aussi le nôtre que
nous aurons à nous trouver le moment nul
xavier bertrand est également candidat à
sa propre réélection en juin
les nordistes ses six millions
d'habitants dans les hauts de france ont
besoin aujourd'hui d'un président à
plein temps et non pas de quelqu'un qui
utilise cette élection régionale pour un
marche-pied à d'autres ambitions
personnelles provient que nos
oppositions ont les yeux rivés sur les
élections
nous on a les yeux rivés au gouvernement
sur les contaminations voilà c'est ça
qui nous obsède